e
call to order the Health and Human
Services oversight committee and while I
thank those who scheduled us here it's
going to be very difficult not to look
out the window at such a beautiful day
so we will move right along the clerk uh
the acting clerk would uh like to know
if it's okay with anybody everybody that
he
records uh the meeting so he can take
notes off of that um uh otherwise we
misquoted I'm going to take that is a a
yes with a subtle threat thank you Mr
role representative Mark Pearson
here representative Bill
King
absent representative Weber here
representative
Murphy representative M donnald here
representative Edwards
absent Senator
gray Senator rosenell here and Senator
aart we
have a
quorum thank you and we have before us
the minutes from our last meeting which
was February
23rd I'm sure we've all had a chance to
look over it for to approve uh motion to
approve made by representative McDonald
a
second a second second a second
by representative Weber the second
time uh two's good all in favor I closed
thank
you Senator Rosenwald abstains because
here it could be argued you found no
errors but no run I
understand nobody left on right mission
be I'm trying to get the title right
Tilly good morning thank you all for
inviting me up here today as you said I
am pinch hitting for the commissioner
this morning it is a beautiful week to
have spring break I have just returned
from my own so I'm a little T and happy
and probably blissfully unaware of
what's exactly going on um so uh what
I'm going to do you uh with your
Indulgence today has just spent a few
minutes talking about our state health
Improvement plan which is something that
I can talk off rattle off off the top of
my head um as many of you know um first
of all you have a copy of uh the outline
of it in front of you um as many of you
know our state health assessment our
state health Improvement plan we
affectionally call those the Sha and the
ship um are developed every 5 to S years
they describe sort of a broad array of
the issues that impact um the health of
people in New Hampshire the purpose
we've had of of developing this plan is
to create a place where everyone um
lives through um a place where everyone
lives well through some coordinated
resources coordinated planning and
coordinated action across many different
sectors most importantly for you to know
this is not just the Department's plan
this really is a plan to help um all of
our partners across the state um towards
achieving some of our common goals the
Sha in the ship is built uh by a state
health Improvement plan advisory Council
that was established by legislation back
in 2020 it's RSA 126a
87 um and the council itself is made up
of a cast of thousands there are over 40
individuals that are on the council um
and it reflects Community Partners state
agencies legislators policy makers
really everyone who has any interest in
the health and well-being of the State
of New Hampshire and that's important
for you to note as you skim through it
because there are things here that are
well out of the four corners of the
Department of Health and Human Services
there are things in here that we don't
necessarily touch we certainly have some
interest in um and so it's important to
think of that that again this is not the
Department's plan but really is a
state's plan every state has a state
health Improvement plan to some degree
but what I am most proud of in this
particular document is that New
Hampshire has moved Beyond essentially
what has always been a list of top 10
things that kill you you know you would
get a plan and it would be tobacco
substance use you could sort of in fact
all of you could write it down off the
top of your head what you would
typically see um with the help of the
council that has been working on this we
really went beyond that and really tried
to look at in a much more holistic way
around four broad areas we looked at
access to opportunity community health
status and outcomes as well as social
connectedness and so the issues and the
goals and objectives again bigger than
DHHS um and you're going to see themes
in there that all of us talk about
regularly and where we often have broad
common ground even though there might be
different approaches to getting to the
same end so things around housing access
to good jobs making kids and families
have enough to eat you know in the
access to opportunity section the
council elevated ideas around Pro
removing barriers um limiting access to
Safe affordable disaster resilient
shelter I.E housing issues around
infrastructure and programs that promote
Financial Independence again making sure
people have access to good jobs in their
communities expanding efforts to improve
nutrition um again making sure kids and
families have things to eat we can get
there in a variety of different ways and
we have appreciated the legislator
legislative support in helping us over
the past few years in all of those areas
in the community section um you'll see
everything from addressing environmental
health concerns to ensuring we have
opportunities for every Community for
lifelong learning from Early Childhood
to adult learning earning we're looking
at again reducing exposure to
environmental contaminants everything
from past to lead exposure testing water
we all know that given the news we've
had right now about the importance of of
our environmental health risks in the
state of New Hampshire um we've uh
elevated reducing Geographic barriers
that limit individuals abilities to
access preferred resources so again
that's around the built environment
making sure that we've got safe places
where you can travel you can bike you
can walk and that you have the
transportation that you need to get to
the places that you want to go um we're
looking at the support for supporting
caregivers and making sure that they are
connected within their community and
expanding programming for lifelong
learning and
enrichment um as we move to health
status and outcome section this is a
little bit more you know what has been
the um in the Wheelhouse of Public
Health in the past you'll see that we've
shair many of the goals that you have
had over um the past few sessions
including expanding access to Affordable
Care for dental services and Behavioral
Health you'll see a notice here to Clos
Loop referral we've all known that
that's been in the news and we're
thankful right now for this group's help
in helping us get to a final close loop
referral contract that was just passed
by governor and Council so it's a place
where both our outside Partners said
this is something that's really
important and we wanted to make sure
that we provided some thank you and some
gratit ude to you all for helping us get
there at the end of the day um also
items in the health um status are again
the pieces that you would expect around
Workforce we're going to hear some stuff
from Danielle today around Workforce
we're going to make sure that we have
access to a Continuum of Care for
Behavioral Health Resources um includ in
improving quality prenatal care labor
and delivery services and postpartum
care you're going to hear a little bit
later from um our folks in Maternal
Child Health around newbor screening all
of these things are connected so while I
can talk about these Health outcomes all
day long I will spare you of that um the
thing that I am most proud of in this
particular plan um was long before our
Surgeon General released his
recommendations on combating loneliness
and social isolation the Sha ship
Council um deeply understood that
loneliness and isolation is much more
than just a bad feeling that it really
Harms both individual um health and our
population's health and as the Surgeon
General also remarked after we published
ours um social isolation is associated
with a greater risk of things like
cardiovascular disease dementia stroke
depression anxiety and premature death
the mortality impact of being socially
disconnected is similar to smoking 15
cigarettes a day and even greater um
there are even greater associations than
with obese
and physical act inactivity the
consequences of a lack of social
connection fuels our substance misuse
issues in the state as well as our youth
Mental Health crisis so state government
doesn't always play the lead role in
addressing some of these issues um there
are things that communities faith-based
organizations others may need to take on
but I think we all have a unique role to
think to play when we think about
strengthening
um systems for things like Aging in
place or supporting stronger connections
among young
families so if the department isn't the
lead on this great plan um for every
single thing what have we committed to
doing across public health and across
the department we have jointly begun
some intense planning along six main
areas one reducing heart disease it's
still the leading killer of the State of
New Hampshire it's not particularly sexy
we don't talk about it a lot but heart
disease is still a number one killer and
so we really need to be thinking in in
more um preventative ways to address um
uh creating opportunities so that we
have address premature death associated
with with heart disease we are looking
at improving the health of mothers for
during and after pregnancy again in many
of your committees you have heard us
talk about the opportunities that we
have to strengthen a system for labor
and delivery and prenatal care
especially given the challenges that we
have around Workforce in the state um we
would be remiss without talking about
improving youth mental health from
prevention to providing acute
residential care it's what we talk about
every day in the news in WMUR um it is
what guides much of our work these days
is around ensuring that we have a much
more robust system from Soup To Nuts for
youth Mental Health Services uh of
course the department has prioritized
addressing the harms of substance misuse
and and so that is not only you know our
uh our services from the doorways and
ensuring that we have that kind of
robust care involved but also ensuring
that we have preventative Services in
place so that we never get down that
path in the first place um it also means
addressing some of the other harms of
substance misuse which lead to premature
death which is of course not only
overdose important overdose but things
like infectious diseases or car or heart
disease that's related from um many
years of substance misuse so those are
things that our department is taking on
as as priorities uh decreasing the
spread of sexually transmitted diseases
I you know I don't think I get up I
can't get away without saying things
like chlamydia um you know in front of
you at some point or another but that's
something that we're continuing to dress
within the department and then finally
reducing um exposure to environmental
hazards we've all heard the impact right
now of Pas we know that our partners at
the Department of Environmental Services
are working closely around pasas and
Water Supplies we're working hand inand
with them um and then down to the
everyday environmental hazards that we
continue to Ste struggle with of things
like lead exposure among children those
are things that are really important to
us we're really promoting issues around
water testing um and ensuring that
kiddos have the appropriate screening at
ages one and two so we do not have a
specific ask of you today but we want we
wanted to be able to provide this to you
to help to ask you to consider as you
wrap up this current session as we think
and as we think about the next bium how
can we ensure that communities have the
resources and the policies to address
these priorities we also again wanted to
thank you for the help that you have
given us and the guidance you have given
us in order to advance many of these
activities I think we are on the same
page in many of these areas you know
from issues such as the expansion of
Medicaid postpartum adult Dental
Investments that the that the
legislature has made in housing around
Behavioral Health substance misuse the
planning we have done for healthy aging
you you have helped us in everything
with policym regarding past to to lead
poisoning um there are all number of
ways that smart policies Investments
strengthen our states um and help our
residents have some better opportunities
we know that money is going to get tight
in the next bium um and I think all
going to have to think very
strategically about where we continue to
support policies and Investments so that
we can make progress on these broad
areas of Health Improvement so that's
the ship and as I I'm happy to answer
more questions around it but we're
really excited about it we are very
grateful for the team on the Sha ship
advisory Council again from all across
the state who have helped Advance these
ideas and we are um very committed to
digging in especially in those six areas
that I mentioned in improving um the
work through the department so thank you
any
questions Senator Rosenwald welcome back
I have two two separate questions if I
could could you catch us up on closed
loop because the last I knew the
executive Council had tabled the
contract it was passed at the last um
executive Council okay so they took it
off yep they took it off the table and
pass okay and secondly
um there's a proposal in nashwa to build
an asphalt plant in the middle of a
lowincome neighborhood of Housing and
Dees is in the process of evaluating the
application for permit their regulations
require them
to um look at the public health statutes
and do doing that but when I asked them
if they were considering things like
asthma rates and children they kind of
looked at me like I they didn't know
what I was talking about so my question
is is
DHS speaking to
Dees
about this application or are they just
working by themselves so we have a very
close relationship one of the benefits
of Public Health sitting over at Hazen
drive as we're physically in the same
building as Dees so we have a great
relationship with them I don't know the
details on that particular proposal but
I can go back and check in um you know
commissioner Scott has been a a great
partner to us and has always welcomed uh
public Health's participation in some of
those processes they have their own um
you know the uh policies that they
follow but they're always have welcomed
us to participate that would be great
because they are citing the Public
Health statutes great thank you thank
you representative
Murphy thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my question um you know I
can't help but notice with your health
Improvement plan access to Opportunities
social connectedness Community Etc which
is great my my question is do you have
the or are the community health you know
workers part of your plan going forward
because obviously they're relatively new
but they're becoming increas inly
apparent to us that they may be part of
the the fabric of Healthcare in its
delivery and the social determinant of
Health Etc in the community so are they
part of your plan absolutely so thank
you so chws are community health workers
are incredibly important um member of
sort of the team of Health Care
Providers or other you know individuals
within our community that can address
some of those social determinant needs
can really develop relationships with
families who are in need and get them
connected to the right services and so
we've thought about them a lot in this
plan and they're when you think about
things like social connectedness they're
really sort of the the key people to
make sure that um folks that you know
and trust in your community can connect
you to the resources that you may need
um we've been thankful that there's been
some work this session around chws and
we thank you for the through Workforce
um bill um and we have also been able to
use some federal resources to ensure
that we can continue funding at least
for the short term um community health
workers in our Family Resource Centers
in our federally qualified Health
Centers and in our local Health
Department so absolutely um I am a huge
fan in fact I will be speaking at the
community health worker um conference
that is occurring next week to which
come representative Merchant thank you
Mr chair can you follow up on the
community health worker in regard The
Advocate in regards to certification the
need for it um because um we recently
had a bill in the house and I sort of
misunderstood it so could you provide
some clarification on the certification
what it does from not just the U
person's competency but what it does
financially as far as being able to
build for it sure I I could um Henry
could probably speak even a little bit
better to this but so currently we don't
have a system for certification for
community health workers in the state
and so we have had to pay for them
through things like grant funding
because we've not without that level of
certification we're not able to Bill
Medicaid um so we have a couple of
different ways uh opportunities to
explore how we could or could not do
that moving forward um how we could
partner with the office of professional
lure and certification um and there are
a number of different ways that other
states have thread this needle and so
we're looking for the next year or so to
figure out what's the best way for New
Hampshire thank you representative
McDonald thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for this report it's very
comprehensive and and very U well put
together uh on page five um talking
about where can we begin to address
inequity in New
Hampshire um it talks about Sullivan
County um and how more than 30% of their
monthly income on housing is spent and
it's above the state average I'm
surprised that's is that the only County
in New Hampshire that that's through up
because I would think a lot of the
Southern counties that would even more
so a problem I think this is a an
artifact of the lower incomes in
Sullivan County and the higher housing
costs so you sort of put those two
things together and you end up spending
a larger proportion of your salary so
places like hillsbor and Rockingham
while the housing costs are astronomical
um sometimes there's a little bit of a
income bump that you might get in those
communities That You Don't See in places
like Claremont or Newport and certainly
um representative Merchant could speak
to that
did I have a followup followup so so it
is unique it is a unique situation
particularly the Sullivan County and and
again you know you could look at a place
like coos coos is hasn't had the same
housing cost rate even though their
salaries are a bit more depressed than
the rest of the state their housing
costs haven't quite gone up as High um
this data is a little bit old and we put
this together in our state health
assessment when in 20122 you know we can
look at that data again moving forward
but at the point in time um Sullivan
really jumped off the page thank
you on page one on the far left thank
you so much for that about uh First
Nations peoples but I notice when I look
at the left column on pages five six and
seven while blacks are mentioned
Hispanics are mentioned uh various
counties and so on there's nothing about
this population I'd like to see more I
think I think that's great we would as
well um one of the statistical problems
we have is the relative small number of
American Indians that are in New
Hampshire that are um in the data sets
that we have that are identified as
American Indian so sometimes we have to
aggregate years of data and so it makes
it hard and masks some of those
disparities that we certainly know exist
throughout the rest of the
country could you give a guess as to how
many individuals I I could not give that
off the top of my head I am sorry and
then were you to
try um people
marry other people yes and so one might
claim oh sure I am
oneir and so it counts but it's
different from two3 yes I'd like to see
data coming forward when you can yes we
we would as well of course not having a
federally recognized tribe in New
Hampshire um make some of that difficult
as all we're one of the only states that
does not have a federally recognized
tribe um again makes it complicated with
our data sources where we can accurately
capture um as with most uh data sources
people self-identify so if someone says
they are we have no reason to believe
that they are not whatever it is they
say they identify as so perhaps for
statistics purposes the fact there is no
federally recognized tribe is not that
important because an individual can
claim a membership even if the feds
don't recognize it correct but we also
don't have a population Center you know
we don't have
um a federally recognized tribe or a
place where um that you would have a
larger proportion of folks who identify
as American Indian living or indigenous
populations okay all very complicated
that doesn't dis um the what it still
supports however is we know that
American Indians have far worse Health
outcomes than many other groups sure
thank you yeah any other questions
representative Merchant thank you Mr
chair going back to Senator Rosen
talking talking about the issue in
nashwa in public health we have
something comparable to that in
Claremont they're trying to use a
transfer station to make it into a um
dumping station quite frankly so how can
I work with the Department on the public
health issue as well as working with
Dees because that location is within
1,000 ft from a elementary school along
with the residential um and we have deep
concerns of what it's going to do from a
public health point of view but we don't
know exactly where to go sure so I would
encourage you to reach out to us reach
out to me directly and I can connect us
with um the right folks over at Dees
we're we do a really nice job of working
in Partnership we do not have public
health authority um you they would have
the authority in that space But as I've
said they've really welcomed our
feedback as they um go through their
policies and processes for
Weber as of the 2020 census
um
one um sorry 1.1% of the New Hampshire
population self-identified as American
Indian and Alaskan native alone
1.1% and there is a category of two or
more races which is 10.2 but it doesn't
say what the mix
is thank you you thank
you anyone else
thank you so much thank
you and the chair
Lipman good morning thank you for the
chance to share a few things um the the
first item um I'd like to share is the
report that's statutorily required from
hb2 with respect to um a couple of
components of what the department was
asked to do in that legislation um one
was to um and whates it look like
because we got a stack of it's a it's a
one one page two-sided with yellow on
the back with yellow on the back got it
yellow is actually the punchline I think
if um I I promise not to read ahead of
you that's okay so um we were asked to
apply for a a plan amendment to add
postpartum coverage which meant going
from 60 days to to a year um and we were
among you know most every state has
subsequently adopted that um aspect and
we were supposed to do it by uh a date
in August which we met that deadline um
we stood it up on October 1st and
um the uh the number of women that have
been able to take advantage of it and
the period from October 1 till um the
end of March were 137 women um I need to
uh sort of go back and and compare that
to what we expected but I think it's
it's on the lower end of our our
expectations that being said you know I
still think it's kind of early um that
uh you know we'll we'll continue to see
that that grow um and then our goal is
to start to add some metrics once we
have some credibility and experience um
but I this was the first metric I could
bring to you and intend to to bring more
um in terms of the um the second the SEC
excuse me the third paragraph on the
second page um had to um look at what we
were doing in terms of the expanding the
access to the really going back to the
future back to what was um in place
before
2011 you know we've made the rule
changes and such to to do that I need to
collect some utilization data on that to
to give you some sense of that and I
think in the next report I'll be able to
do
that representative
Weber I'm recalling a news report
recently about our birth rate having
declined to its lowest level in
In Living memory or maybe any memory um
and is the are the lower numbers in line
with that or would you know so actually
or are they even lower than you would
have expected giving a declining birth
rate my my recollection in in for the 22
data um is actually that New Hampshire
was one of the only states that showed
an increase in the the birth rate okay
so maybe that was a national story and I
misunderstood I'm sorry and so I I don't
really have a a feel for this year but
um you know I think that at least in the
Medicaid side I'm seeing fairly stable
um and we have done things to try to
support um hospitals being able to and
doctors part of hb2 um was uh allowed us
to uh Target a rate increase for um
people who deliver babies U also the the
freestanding birthing centers and the
prior year we had increased the uh
reimbursement to hospitals for doing
births um I think it was 34% for the
small hospitals and 24% for the for the
larger hospitals to you know try to
stabilize um what's going on in terms of
the subsidy that Medicaid May um May do
I know
um the not to sort of weigh into sort of
the bills that are currently active but
one one bill of concern to me as the
Medicaid director is the one that deals
with loss of consortion which I know
isn't in front of this committee but the
concern is that particularly for um
obstetrical Services the malpractice
Market has hardened and particularly for
nurse midwives and you know concerned
about um you know if if there's an
impact on if that legislation were to
pass what's the impact on on
um rates and in terms of you know does
that have some unintended consequence at
least on the access
side Senator
Rosenwald thank you
so Henry are are these
people were they eligible because they
were not eligible for Medicaid expansion
but were eligible under that
250% of poverty I think it is for the
pregnant women yes and might some of
them have become eligible for for
Medicaid in a different way let's say
expansion and so there maybe actually
more than 137 women right I I think
you're hitting on a point you know it's
in terms of trying to predict this in
terms of where people land on
eligibility is affected by a lot of
factors and you know with the economy um
with wages going up in different things
that people may land or land in
different categories or they you know
what we're seeing in Medicaid expansion
as an example it hasn't come down as
much as we thought it would it's come
down a lot from like almost 97,000 to
59,000 but um I think that it just may
be the and I'll have to look into it
more I think it's a fair question in
terms of you know where people are
landing when they give uh birth and are
they getting the 12 months of coverage
um so I I think there's more to more to
look into there and I I just didn't
enough time to do more than this for
this month's report thank you any
further questions for Mr
Lipman none for the moment but we may
bring you back at the end if I do have
two more reports to uh well thank you
for what you've done and please go on to
the next two sure and um Dr Finny also
has a report to to to share on that give
you a dental update good you know we're
actually celebrated the one-year
anniversary of dental uh you know the
beginning of uh April April 1st marked
uh starting our second year um hard to
believe um the the report I wanted to go
over is this one um the bright
orange and um just wanted to share um
going to jump to slide three and there
there are slide numbers on these this
month um on the bottom right hand side
just want to give you some comparative
information that was compiled by CMS um
in terms of New Hampshire compared to
other New England states on the unwind
and and the United States and I'd like
to point out a couple statistics here
for you um probably four to the to the
right is the percent renewed on an expar
basis meaning that the department had
enough information to not require the
person to fill out a new application
particularly um and uh what we're seeing
there is that you know we seen a
significant Improvement in this area in
terms of being able to renew um we had
the fourth highest uh expart rate in the
nation you know we began in the the the
unwind um we were under 20% in our first
number of months it it does depend on
the type of population that you're
you're also un unwinding or reconsider
reconsidering so we've made a lot of
progress there in helping people um who
are eligible maintain um
coverage the other thing on the far
far right would be um the um the percent
pending at the end of the month
basically you know we hear a lot of
things about how New Hampshire sometimes
the eligibility processing isn't as fast
as we like but in terms of backlog
compared to other states I think um you
know while we have areas to improve I'm
not going to say that we don't um but
you know on a relative basis um you know
we're we were second in New England and
and you know well below the the national
average and
um also uh and the month that we're
looking at that page three is January
which is the latest published
information and then the percent that
loss coverage is uh going back towards
the left is um the
uh there's a column called number
terminated from Medicaid and the percent
terminated you know we had 518
individuals out of
8,924 that uh didn't maintain coverage
which was almost a 91% renewal rate
um and again you know in terms of where
we are in the unwine we're at the the
part of the unwine where we're dealing
with CFI and nursing home which we
expected would be much higher
retention um and um the the next page
page four is just um the month of
December a preceding month just for
comparison so I feel like um again again
there's there's always room to improve
but we we're doing a pretty good job um
comparatively
um on uh Slide Five is the EXP parte
renewal rates and there you can see you
when we started the unwind um Again part
based on the population we're unwinding
we had a low of 18% and um we hit a high
of 81% in um the first quarter of of uh
of uh 20 3 uh Federal fiscal year I
guess that would be um and you know saw
you know an increase from 76 to 81 to 79
that's when we're hitting the most
vulnerable populations and again you
know typically once you're in a nursing
home and under Medicaid or in um CFI or
other waiver populations you're you're
going to see people not churn as
much um the next page six and seven are
are
um kind of the the enrollment numbers um
the page six at the top gives you the
statistic as of the basically the end of
March which is the onee mark right we we
had
182,780 people enrolled in total in the
program you know that's down from a high
of 251,000 plus individuals but at the
bottom you can see if you look at the
last line on the page the grand total um
you know the week that things sort of
shut down during the public health
emergency we were at 177 420 um at the
end of uh end of March we were at 182
753 um and um what we see in the next
slide just during during the month we
see very we see uh fluctuations
typically in the middle of the month
we'll see a higher number of individuals
so as of the 22nd we had
184,000 people enrolled in the program
but again when we finish going through
renewal activity it'll probably come
closer to
183,000 um will be probably where we
likely will end um the month of April um
the next page page eight is I think
something I wanted to I think is
probably the most valuable these next
slides the slides that I've covered
about what's going on in enrollment um
on November 6 was the low Point um in
the unwind in terms of enrollment and
you can see you know a couple of groups
that we've been worried about um the
purple line I know it may not be
perfectly easy to see but the purple
line and the yellow line are children
and we've seen that um increase by you
know almost a little over three 3,000
children have come um onto the Medicaid
Program um you know there was a concern
New Hampshire was
you know highlighted as being a state
that lost a lot of children that part of
it is we've seen I think in last time I
presented to you we've had family income
we've had a higher proportion of our our
families be in the 300 and 400% we only
go up to
323 um which is uh among the highest
meaning the most favorable eligibility
opportunities we've seen School
enrollment go down but um what I think
we're seeing play out here is the
continuous coverage children are now
given um 12 months of continuous
coverage that was a requirement not just
in New Hampshire but across the
country um also in the
um the other categories not so much big
and Medicaid expansion has seen an
increase as well um from from the low
point but again we're down from almost
97,000 individuals what I I think is
going on a little bit there we need to
do a little bit more research is a lot
of people looking to that eligibility
group when they're waiting for other
determinations other benefits to come
into play like if they're they're
waiting for disability determination or
or or other things this is a way they
can get coverage until U maybe a waiver
is is considered but um you know in
terms of the entire program the the mix
has shift a little bit towards more
towards Medica Aid uh expansion the
granted Advantage Program which you know
has the higher Federal match
but I think this is this is a graph I
think I get a lot of information out of
um and then um Pages uh page nine um is
really our detailed report that we we
look at in terms of on a monthly basis
in terms of closures and here we're
looking at both people who are protected
in the continuous coverage as well as
individuals who are just regular
renewals and as as uh is sort of
supported by the expart rate we had
91.6% of the the regular renewals retain
coverage um and 91.6 excuse me 88.5% of
the the protected population you can see
protected population is down to the very
little there was only 29 protected
people that went through and we expect
to have run through all the protected
people um by the month of May um and we
we did slow down with the the most most
vulnerable and I'm glad we did based on
some of the challenges we're seeing and
I I'll get to that a little bit more in
a
moment um page 10 is just uh totals up
all the activity by every month
um page 11 and 12 are
um focusing on an area that I haven't
reported on before um and this is a
dashboard that we're looking to further
develop but this is a month by month
look the the waiver population was given
additional protections um in terms of
the medical evaluation assessment that
has to be done on an annual basis um
people did not have to complete this
during the The Continuous coverage
period so there's some people that have
not had that checked for almost four
years and um so we're going through the
that that process here the the yellow
highlight is the number of meas that
we're looking at you can it's not until
page 12 where you see um um in the month
of uh March uh and looking at February
where we start to see some closures
around um you know we've had 66 closures
on on almost 1,200 um medical
evaluations but we've been the
Department's been using a number of
different strategies to try to
um get these evaluations done give
people an opportunity to appeal we've um
we've asked CMS to extend from 15 days
to 30 days um the opportunity to appeal
and maintain coverage because I think po
the populations in this group um you
know are maybe have a a lower capacity
to respond quickly and so trying to give
them more time we're waiting for that
approval we did also ask for another
temporary authority to on the
um the income verification side of um in
nurs people in nursing facilities are
allowed up to $2,500 of uh of Assets in
terms of asset verification is to try to
move things along a little bit faster as
if if everything else lines up and they
have you know $2,500 or less in assets
we're not required to to verify that
$2500 which helps move things along a
little bit
faster um we we'll probably have more to
say about some some other things that
we're looking at this place this is you
know the population we're most concerned
about the people that are home alone and
you know depend on their services that
they
get
um then just pull a a couple of slides
that really um show go back to sort of
financial eligibility and um the the
darkest color there on page 13 um was
the month of March and you can see that
here just there were 342 individuals
that we processed in the home the CFI
basis on at least on a financial
eligibility basis um all but five U made
it through the financial um uh
standpoint and that um the ability you
know of the ones that were um more than
two-thirds of them ended up being able
to be expart review which is sort of the
bottom right hand
corner um you know there were um on the
left hand corner there's a little chart
in terms of the five people
um one was for income was one was failed
to do the redetermination and three may
have been for other reasons such as they
moved or um that they uh there other
change in circumstance change in
household composition that that thing
things like that and then um the next
page uh 14 is just looking at those
numbers on a percentage
basis um then on page 15 is looking at
at the nursing facilities here here on
the top left there were 278 individuals
in the month of March all but four made
it through the financial redetermination
process um again a um on the bottom
right a high level of passive expart
renewal um and then on the bottom left
there's one person on income and three
for other reasons
um and then page 16 is um just the
percentages for those same numbers um
page 17 um is uh sort of where uh CFI
elig eligibles are um the CFI case
manager asked us to sort of lift this up
a little bit more you know we have um
seen a decline in the CFI um
population we do want to see that go in
the opposite direction because when you
compare the cost to the state to keep
people in their homes versus an
institution in most cases it's
considerably
less um as you may also remember um the
system of care that was included um in I
believe hb2 as well the department was
asked to um apply for a waiver to
implement presumptive eligibility
for the CFI
population um again there we met our
deadline in terms of submitting as part
of our 1115 waiver to include that um
all indications are right now that we
expect that we'll get that approval um
by the end of June it will take us a
little time to stand it up uh system
wise but that's going to help I think
there um and I think you know we you
know I think we have every reason to
want the CFI population relative to
other populations to
increase
um think any questions you have on this
uh representative Merchant thank you Mr
chair as always Mr Libman I want to say
thank you for
your due diligence the work that you put
into it we state benefits tremendously
from it and I want to say publicly the
thank you in regards to the CFI is there
what I'm trying to get to some sort of
comparison to the waivers that are
hopefully growing compared to nursing
home um at least the County nursing
homes because if I understand it correct
financially it's better probably for the
state financially as well as well as for
the patient psychologically and
otherwise to probably age in place is
there any kind of comparative numbers
looking at nursing home occupancy versus
the use of cfis
yes I I think I don't have I think
that's probably a good thing to maybe
have a longer discussion and prepare
some information for you but you know I
think the department would say is that
you know as we compare to other states
our Reliance on
institutionalization versus um home um
the the hp2 rate increases um we had um
way point I believe came in and met with
a department talking about what a big
difference that's made in terms of
they're able to increase the the number
of people they're serving and the number
of hours so I think part of our
CFI problem has been the rate side of it
that it's was hard to hire workers to to
to do the in home care um but I know
that
um they were they took the initiative to
come and talk to us uh appreciation for
what was done by the legislature to
improve those those kind of rates I
think you know sometimes we can be um
it's worth making the investment in the
you know the Home Care side um more than
we than we have I think it's seems like
we're spending more money in the long
we're follow up follow up no thank you
no Senator
rosenal you thank you Henry I love data
this is
great um I have two questions on
slide six I think it
is maybe it's seven six or seven yes um
we're showing a
decrease versus prepandemic
among individuals with
disabilities
and um that's concerning to me could you
talk more about
why why those three distinct
populations have a lower case load yeah
I think
um the children's with disabilities is
one we did a little research into and
part of that is um you know children who
were children during the start of the
continuous coverage have moved out of
the children's category into to other
categories in other words um in terms of
the adults with disabilities um you know
I I don't I need to do a little bit more
on on that and some some analytics we've
been focusing on mental health and
children um in terms of trying to better
understand what's going on there but I
think that you know in terms of what I
get for like phone calls um to to help
people on there's been very little in
the waiver areas rather than in
CFI that that I've taken phone calls on
and you know try to help people but um I
can try to get a little bit more
information for you there um I think the
other thing that we're also seeing is um
potentially some lag in catching up with
um some determinations in the disability
um um unit in ter because we've had a
change in contractor in terms of doing
some of that work but I'd like to come
back to you with something more specific
than that that would be that would be
great um on different topic um with the
CFI um with the rate
increases I know we can't
require
the agencies to pass
through the money but what kind of
reporting has the department gotten from
the organiz ations that get their CFI
contracts in terms of how much they've
been able to increase compensation for
the direct service
providers um have two- part answer the
first part actually is uh in regulations
that were published on Monday CMS is
implementing an 80% requirement of the
rate to go um and I don't I have to look
more into the regulation in terms of the
timing of that
I I do know um anecdotally like Waypoint
gave us some statistics on how much
they've improved salaries and um trying
um name's escaping me for the moment but
they an in home they gave like a $5
raise to their staff um and they
actually because of the also the the
spending plan money that was available
through arpa they actually in
anticipation actually were early in
terms of implementing their their salary
increases um but um we do get some
reporting on that I don't get that
directly but um the department does and
I can bring that one back too for um
some followup um part of their spending
plan is yeah
yep representative Merchant thank you Mr
chair uh in regards to the CFI waiver
is there some numbers that look at how
much
we provide to the agency per waiver
compared to the cost to be per day
inside of a nursing home yes there is
and I wish I could remember today what
what the exact numbers are but we as
part of our our waiver proposal we we
sort of um put that out I think the
savings is
probably rather than just guess here I
think it it's it's a pretty significant
uh savings over and someone here
remembers that number um but that's okay
M just thank you back to you on that
one um representative McDonald thank you
Mr chairman and thank you Mr Litman um
on page uh nine um and I I think I've
touched on this before but a different I
thought hopefully it's a different
question than before uh total closure by
reasons fail to read is number two fail
to redetermined
I know when I was in the department a
case worker and this might not be a
question for you but a case worker had
some discretion if someone was elderly
in a nursing home for example that
tended to be an annual readed because
their circumstances weren't likely to
change but a younger person working or
possibly changing jobs having another
child they were on like a six-month
cycle or maybe even less depending on um
you know different time frames and and
factors do you know if that's still the
case so we have
um again in part for the first round of
redeterminations we put the the nursing
homes and the facilities towards the
back because we knew that there's more
that people had to get ready for to get
through that process like they have to
get bank statement and life insurance
policy values sometimes and things like
that we also um it added 30 days on to
the time that they had to usually it was
30 days they have to responded we used
the temporary authority to increase that
to 60 days so that people had more time
to to react to that in the waiver um
populations um in the CFI area they were
also using um a concept called bridging
to try to give people more time to to
respond or to get things done um it'll
be interesting to see um how these
author ities they're they run through
the end of uh
2024 um what What U what the impact of
when some of that is backed off but I
think we've learned a lot by going
through this and um we do a lot more in
terms of noticing an Outreach than than
probably the time you were in the
department even the time since I began
in the department
that you know we we've used the color
letters you know the pink letter to let
give people um heads up the yellow
letter to warn them and then if they
close we use a blue letter to say it's
if it's blue it's not too late to renew
um we're sharing lists with um with the
nursing facilities um we're we're
looking at other options for um trying
to to provide information that for those
people are being paid that want to make
sure that the people who can be eligible
get eligible like um working with
different with different groups and um
we're trying to create more transparency
so that that the the organizations can
help themselves and helping the person
and uh some of those things are still
works in progress but I think we're
doing a lot more to try to help people
stay covered okay follow followup so is
there an average redetermination period
like is it if not six months is it like
eight or nine or so so we're in terms of
someone is required to be annually
redetermined under normal circumstances
or if there's a change in circumstances
um there's also if if someone is also
receiving snap and and Medicaid benefits
they can be redetermined on a six-month
basis if if it's to their benefit and
you no further questions I did want to
um if I could Mr chairman um there was a
question about the certification of uh
community health workers is when we talk
certification um under Medicaid we're
really talking about someone who is um
under New Hampshire law um credentialed
through licensed or certified through
oplc um and that's what level they need
to be able to to build um Medicaid
um and uh if you want to hear about
dental we we can do that I always want
to hear about Dental in fact I have a
dental appointment this afternoon I will
give them your regards I I hope you get
a gold star I don't want a gold tooth
but I'll take a gold star thank you I
used to want stickers in my previous
committee but that's another
story well good morning and and thank
you for um allowing me a few minutes to
just bring you up to speed on adult
Dental uh we were very excited to
celebrate our first anniversary on April
1st I can't believe that a year has
passed already um and I just want to
extend my thanks once again
um for all of the support and interest
in the adult Dental benefit we wouldn't
be here without uh legislative support
so thank
you um the first part of um our report
has to do with service utilization and
program
Administration I think you can see that
from implementation in April of 23
coming up to March of
24 um we've had a steady increase in the
number of unique members being served
every month and the number of claims
being
submitted um you know with a few little
waverings uh December and January were a
little bit dicey there were some weather
issues and then holidays so that is not
an
unexpected um drop in those numbers but
you can see that February and March came
back um very strong so um these claim
totals were produced the first or second
week of April and we were just short of
35 00 claims and slightly greater than
2500 unique members served um in the
month of March
2024 um and you know we uh have served
over 12,000 unique members to this point
and I would say that that number also um
is increasing on a monthly
basis um the next page gets into our our
Network dashboard which is hot off the
press uh two days ago we're now up to
165 providers that includes um oral
surgeons we also were very happy uh to
add a pred onist in the last couple of
months and in ongoing efforts of
Northeast Delta and DentaQuest they have
had over 60 office recruitment visits
since January 1st and those recruitment
visits include not only reaching out to
dentists who are not yet enrolled in the
program but coming back around to the
folks that enrolled early um in the
spring last year and checking in with
them to see how things are going how is
the benefit working for you how is it
working for the members that they serve
um and what has their experience been
and also most importantly if they're at
a point where they could potentially um
take on a greater load of members so you
know those efforts are ongoing
um when you look at the county breakdown
chesher is the the county with the least
providers at this point um when we move
to the next page and start talking about
mobile services you will see that uh we
are in the throws of getting that first
date nailed down for chesher to do a
mobile clinic um and then the the two
areas uh Sullivan and Carol County have
yellow arrows and those are now in
regular rotation with the mobile
services and in particular in Sullivan
County we're working on an additional
location um so that we can increase the
footprint there and this planning I will
tell you is is
ongoing
um the you know when you look at the
schedule today that I present to you for
mobile services it's much more robust
than 3 months ago or four months ago and
to that end and on April 11th we met
with Northeast Delta and DentaQuest and
solve who actually does um the mobile
services to really strategize what does
the mobile service portion of this um
Network look like for the longer term
initially we thought that that was going
to be um a temporary measure and we
realize now that just because of
Workforce issues and um shortage areas
for providers we're going to have to
keep using the mobile services and
really have them become uh a stable
portion of our Network where um our
visits and then um in terms of
stakeholder engagement um I do want you
to know that probably the only meetings
that we have curtailed at this point are
those for the technical implement ation
because at this point we have all our
systems in place that uh move the data
back and forth between the state and the
two um Dental
organizations um Northeast Delta and
dest uh but all of our other meetings
are still going Full Tilt um just as
they were a year ago we are not sitting
back and saying okay you know you have
the program this is it we realize there
are areas that we need to strengthen um
so the um New Hampshire oral health
Coalition has been key in our activities
uh they very graciously held the
birthday party for legislators that was
held on March 28th and I hope that some
of you were able to be there and have
some birthday cake um again that was to
show our thanks uh for your support and
and the work that everyone did to get us
to the point of finally launching this
benefit the the Coalition is also host
ho hosting a summit on May 9th which
basically will be an opportunity for
stakeholders and public members to come
in and talk about what happened over the
last few years that led up to the
benefit how the first year has gone and
then to have some open discussion about
uh what do the next few years look like
with the benefit um it's very important
to us that we have input from the public
uh we need to know um where things are
working well where we have areas that we
need to work um and so I have to say
that Northeast Delta Dental as well as
dest have been uh very good partners in
this Venture and they are committed to
making sure that we develop all of the
the parts of the benefit that we need so
that we can serve all of the
members so I don't know if you have any
questions questions at this
point representative
Weber thank you thank you for all this
work and it's it's great to have gotten
this far um do you have a location for
cheser county
S don't know I don't know loation Sal is
is doing that and I'm sorry that I don't
have I was just
curious if if it Bec comes a problem if
somebody could give me a call or send
shoot me an email I can I can with the
requirements I'd be glad to try and okay
help find somewhere thank you very much
I appreciate that Senator Rosenwald
thank you thank you for your work on
this on the slightly different question
of
children um as you know I went to visit
this public health
school-based programmed where the care
is delivered by
hygienists is the department working or
will the department be trying to
include coverage uh under Medicaid for
that silver diamond treatment and the
temporary
Restorations as that we we are working
on right now um you know the basic
Services um of cleanings and regular
Fluoride Varnish and sealants have
always been covered in those locations
and we are working to expand to the
other um fluide and the the temporary
Restorations could you give me an update
please on one of my perennial questions
on loan forgiveness to Current Dental
students who will make a commitment and
to relatively new dentists are out in
the field who would like to make a
commitment for loan
forgiveness there are actually two
programs there is the state loan
repayment program and we actively are
you know advertising the fact that that
Loan program is available uh messaging
goes up on the state's social media
sites from time to time um we I share
that information with the dental Society
to to put out um I also include that
information for the offices that I have
to survey for the children's benefit and
now I'm happy to add that the uh
Northeast Delta Dental has made a very
sizable um commitment to loan
repayment um over the tri-state area
they serve Maine Vermont and New
Hampshire and um I have been able to sit
on a steering committee for that loan
repayment program uh to help guide them
because like the state program there is
a requirement for the individuals to
treat Medicaid members so um we actually
are having a meeting June 3 uh where we
will bring together folks from Northeast
Delta as well as the state to talk about
where we are right now today with both
loan repayment programs and what does
the future look for that um for us to
work together to make sure that um
dentists are recruited to the state and
are aware that those two um programs are
available at some point could you send
me a onepage or maybe send it to the
whole committee and anyone who wishes to
look at it will have an opportunity to
questions seeing none thank you so much
the chair recognizes as she
approaches administrator Courtney Keane
from the division of Public Health
Services for the newborn screening
annual report which is wisely entitled
newborn screening program thank you
yes all right good morning Mr chairman
and members of the committee my name is
Courtney Keane and I'm the administrator
for the newborn screening program
um for the Maternal Child Health section
in the Bureau of family health and
nutrition and the division of Public
Health Services I have direct oversight
over the newborn screening
program yes yep is
that is that better yes great
sorry um I am pleased to present the
newborn screening 2022 annual
report RSA
13210 requires that a physic phys
birthing facility Midwife or other
healthc care provider attending the
birth of a newborn to screen the infant
for a panel of heritable disorders the
statute also includes a clause 13210 C
which allows parents or Guardians to
decline the screening if they so
desire the newborn screening program is
responsible for ensuring that all
infants who are born in New Hampshire
are screen for 36 heritable conditions
this is specific to New Hampshire the
condition itions that New Hampshire
screens for are based on what the
recommended uniform screening panel also
known as the rusp have approved the
newborn screening advisory committee
votes on approving or denying additions
to the New Hampshire newborn screening
panel based on the following
criteria the disorder is well defined
with a known incidence the disorder is
associated with significant morbidity or
mortality the disorder can be detected
with a screening test that is ethical
safe accurate and cost effective
effective treatment exists for the
disorder and that early treatment
meaning before the onset of symptoms is
more effective in improving Health
outcomes than
later the program is also responsible
for ensuring that screening is done in a
timely manner and any presumptive
positive or out-of-range result is
reported to a provider the goal of
newborn screening is early
identification and treatment if
needed the program is is reporting 2022
data due to the length of time it takes
to receive a confirmation of a disorder
it takes about a year to confirm a
disorder in calendar year 2022 there was
12,135 births with 99% of them being
screened of the infants who were
screened there was
732 infants who had an abnormal or
presumptive positive screen of those 30
had a confirmed heritable
condition 2022 was a year of Staff
transitions at the
department the program went from one FTE
to 2.5 FTE which brought the program to
Staffing capacity the positions are
supported by the revolving funds and a
Federal grant the program consists of a
nurse consultant a follow-up specialist
and a quality improvement
specialist each position has a unique
role in making sure that infants are
screened within 24 to 48 hours of life
and followed up if they have an abnormal
or presumptive positive
screen the program relies on timeliness
of specimen for optimal
results the program focused on two
quality improvement activities improving
timeliness and decreasing unsatisfactory
specimen the first quality improvement
activity was timeliness of specimen
being shipped to the contracted
laboratory the University of
Massachusetts Chan medical school the
program worked with each birth facility
to confirm pickup of specimen by either
UPS or City Express by streamlining this
process at each birth facility it is
reduced any potential delays by The
Courier each birth facility is provided
a quarterly timeliness report which
focuses on measures within the control
of the hospital staff which means drawn
between between 48 24 and 48 Hours of
Life historical data demonstrates
significant progress since 2015 meeting
the target of 95% of specimen being
collected within that 24 to 48 hours
report the program also worked with
birth facilities to decrease the number
of unsatisfactory
specimen unsatisfactory specimen are
poor soaks contaminated drawn prior to
24 hours of age improperly dried and
clot
it any unsatisfactory specimen requires
a repeat test the infant must return to
a facility where staff have the
expertise to draw the
specimen most infants go back to their
birth facility however some go to their
PCP a repeat test also incurs additional
costs to the
facility from January to December of
2022 birth facility spent
$3,368 on repeat specimen
this includes repeats due to abnormal
results and unsatisfactory
specimen by working with birth
facilities to reduce the unsatisfactory
repeats repeat specimen the program saw
a
2,628 decrease compared to
2021 the program continues to
collaborate with the birth facilities to
keep reducing the
numbers of unsatisfactory specimen thus
reducing the cost
the future of newborn screening newborn
screening remains a dynamic field
advances in science and technology are
ongoing and continue to impact the
newborn screening
program the program will continue to
monitor data quality and provide
unsatisfactory specimen in timeliness
reports to all birth facilities in the
state in the coming year the program
will maximize the use of data and
quality improvement recommendations to
ensure no infant is missed excluding
those
declined and all other infant vestment
are tested and followed up on in a t
timely
manner the program applied for the
United States Health Resources and
service Administration State newborn
screening system priorities program and
was awarded the
grant the grant supports screening
programs to address State specific
challenges and Implement new quality
improvement activities such as improving
and expanding the new in screening
management information system
implementing screening for new
conditions added to the recommended
uniform screening panel or the rusp and
increasing access to treatment and
followup for individuals and families
identified with a heritable condition
through the newborn screening
program I want to thank you for this
opportunity to present the 2022 annual
report I'd be happy to answer any
questions you might have Miss Kean on
page nine this wonderful little chart
here
um I would assume on on towns on the
border uh people in plastow might go God
help them to stward hospital in havil or
a little further west to Lawrence or
something is there any way that we get
that
data no so this is only babies born in
New Hampshire okay uh second question is
there an increase in out of hos Hospital
births because of distance or because I
noticed Parkland and Derry is not on
this list so you're in Dairy and I'm
just plotting oh my gosh getting the car
quick and whoops we didn't make it um is
do you see a an increase in B should
that take place would it be fair to
assume then somebody continues the trip
into the hospital where the test is made
so there was a slight increase in out of
home um out of Hospital births um
midwives this is midwives too so
midwives have these filter papers um
that they use and draw the sample on the
infants good well thank you
representative Murphy thank you Mr
chairman um I have a few questions my
one of the questions we talked about
previously you have 99% get screened
yeah and I'm assuming based on the chart
on six that that is a blood test that
done because there was clotting and
there was insufficient blood noted are
are any of the screenings done currently
that involve you know urine or
saliva
no this report is specific to the blood
only the blood yes so the 99% all of
them are basically blood tests correct
are these blood tests taken from the
baby the infant when born or are they
placental blood removed or this is from
the baby itself yep so there's um it's a
paper that's about this big um and it
has four circles at the bottom of it and
it's taken from the infant's heel So
after 24 hours of Life blood is taken
from the infant to test for our
conditions this is a heel stick what
you're talking about that yes
okay and so I'm assuming then that you
know to to any other tests that would
require silver or saliva or urine would
be an increased cost it would be thank
you representative McDonald thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for taking my
question I'm going to show my ignorance
of which I have an abundance um
heritable does that mean
inherited okay I kind of assume so um
I've nothing heard that term before if I
may a to follow up follow up um getting
back to the Chairman's question about
like Parkland isn't on this list on on
page nine I know Franklin has a hospital
that's not on this list various
hospitals aren't on this list could you
explain why that's the case do they not
they not do this
or so they have to have a maternity or
labor and delivery unit okay to do this
test however hospitals that don't have a
facility still have the test so if a
baby comes into the emergency room at
Franklin and delivers the hospital has
one of these papers to do the test on
the
child okay but does not attribute excuse
me did I
one uh but if it's if the baby is born
there and they have to do the paper but
it's not recorded as having Franklin
having done it or yes okay but it just
hasn't happened there correct okay it's
very infrequent that we have a hospital
conduct a filter paper on they're called
filter papers um on a baby that does not
have a labor and delivery or maternity
unit would the Assumption be the reason
not all Hospital hits are here could be
they're very very small and it's very
expensive to maintain this unit or they
are for profit facilities and do not see
this as a good loss leader for them I'm
Tilly hi good good morning again so um
thank you thank you this is a great
report and I think you all are asking
the right questions around access to
labor and delivery services in the state
of New Hampshire um I often show and and
my colleague Henry does as well there's
a map of New Hampshire sort of right
across the middle of the state in some
ways it's Route 11 from Claremont over
to Rochester we have lost all our
birthing facilities there we've also
lost facilities in the southern part of
the state as you notice with Parkland
and so um this is all a place where
you're seeing potentially increased
numbers of out of Hospital births as as
the question that you ask sometimes we
see people move to uh Midwife facilities
um sometimes that's in the home
sometimes there are some birthing
facilities run by midwives there the
reason for those uh facilities to close
are multifactoral often it is because
there are small numbers um Workforce is
really the biggest thing that drives it
to in order to have 24-hour coverage to
deliver babies is really expensive
especially for those small hospitals um
so that's why we've seen many of those
critical access hospitals um close down
and then of course the for-profit
hospitals have their own um
rationalization for the services that
they choose to provide yeah Senator
Rosen Wald thank Youk you
um we've heard
anecdotally that some women are choosing
home birth because they can't afford the
co-pay the or the co- Insurance the out
of pocket cost for either a hospital or
a freestanding birthing center and I'm
sure you guys have heard those reports
too but while that's concerning to me my
question is a home
birth that um would that
require the attempt to do the newborn
screening as well yes no matter who
attended yep even if it was just your
best friend yep thank you cuz they would
know about it they can opt out though as
well well they can but somehow if your
friend was attending your birth they
would somehow know they were required to
do newborn screening yeah so that's a
tricky question um most at home births
have some type of midwife following them
for their care I don't know and maybe
you do of any person who's not had any
prenatal care and then delivers at home
um but if a midwife is part of the
process they have one of these filter
papers that they would offer to the
family and the family can decline if
they would like to so yes so someone my
best friend could deliver but the
Midwife would be there to support and
representative Merchant thank you Mr
chair with the evolution of at home
births or birth not inside of the
hospital is it possible in this chart
not for this time maybe for the future
to include a line in here for at home
burs that we can look at that point in
time is percentage are you referring to
the one on the last page on last page
page n yes we are currently in the works
of that um it just hasn't been done for
2022 data so the next report will
include out of or out of Hospital
births follow up on next question and
also on that report it's this is very
insightful is looking at just the
percentage but looking at overall burs
if you will within a facility because
what I'm trying to understand is that if
we're seeing that go down consistently
so we look at the claramont Rochester
that band in the middle if we're
starting to see a decrease in Birds
inside of a hospital hospital is
probably economically um they may be
vulnerable to
closure so is there any way to get so a
trend of numbers of what's Happening not
just a percentage which is what you're
dealing with here but looking at the
number of births being um done within a
facility during over a period of time
because if it's trending down B
drastically that's probably not a good
thing in some ways can I ask a
clarifying question would you like to
see the number of infants born at each
hospital is that your question so like
in that
region yes because it what I'm trying to
get to is in certain parts of the state
the rural parts of the state if we're
seeing that go down dramatically for
whatever reason it's probably a
indication that something's happening um
it could be because of the number of
residents in the area itself which is
natural it could be because of other
economic issues going
on I was just going to say we are
tracking that data it is um we're
working closely with Medicaid and public
health together to understand those um
Dynamics especially in those rural areas
around where people are getting their
care Al we're also tracking that for
example in Sullivan County are you going
up to Dartmouth are you going down to
chesher those are all part of the data
that we're we're following but we can
report any further
the chair recognizes Danielle Hernandez
administrated division of Public Health
Health good morning chairman Pearson and
members of the committee Daniel
Hernandez I am the administrator of the
Health Professions data center or hbdc
that sits alongside the state office
office of rural Health under rural
health and Primary Care section and the
division of Public Health Services that
is a mouthful and it never gets easier
how many business cards do it
[Laughter]
take I have to cut some of them out
there um it is my pleasure to uh be
presenting highlights of the
2023 um report on the New Hampshire
Healthcare Workforce and data collection
you did receive the full report
electronically at the beginning of the
week um but you should have in front of
you the um executive summary and some
data tables to follow along um to with
this
presentation
okay oh all right everybody set so the
State Office of rural health is
statutorily required to receive
available data and collect data through
provider surveying during the licensed
renewal Cycles to assess the current and
anticipated supply of primary care
providers in the state the data is
immensely valuable right it supports and
it strengthens Federal shortage
designation which our office coordinates
um and that brings providers and grant
funding to medically underserved areas
of the state it supports Recruitment and
Retention initiatives among others the
state loan repayment program National
Health Service Corp um it supports the
development of new and expansion of
existing educational and training
programs most recently
um Coos County Family Medicine Residency
in Berlin and chesher Family Medicine
Residency in keen and of course
emergency preparedness um hpdc is the
only entity in the state that exists as
a central repository for advanced
practice Healthcare Workforce data and
maintains a level of detail necessary
for accurate medical Behavioral Health
and oral health Workforce estimates as
such data requests continue to increase
each year from our uh Partners in higher
education provider associations Health
policy and practice organizations um and
of course chhs public health programs to
inform their um grants Workforce
initiative strategies um and internal
reports in addition to these annual
reports hbdc releases uh annual provider
Workforce data reports that can be found
on the rural health and Primary Care web
pages and those links are provided for
you under the introduction section and
the executive summary
uh these visual data reports have
dashboards on survey response rates
practice status uh demographics
Education and Training practice capacity
distribution uh patient access
indicators anticipated Supply and um
rurality okay so I'm going to move on
here to page
one um all right so table one on page
one um shows license types included in
this year's report um for medical
providers and Behavioral Health
Providers um and the data collection
period so um the report reflects data
collected in 2021 as our turnaround
period for reporting is two years after
the data is collected um some providers
you'll notice do have two-year combined
data that's to ensure reliable um St
statistics because of um for mental
health practitioners and psychologists
there's a Mal distribution of providers
by um licensed renewal year and then for
others like adex um or alcohol and drug
counselors in the state there's just a
low number of providers so combining
that two-year data gives us U more
stable statistics
there table two shows survey response
rates for State fiscal year
2021 um and you can compare the 2021
rates to um the 2020 rates in the column
right next to it for notable changes um
we can see here that there are
significant increases in in compliance
with aprns in the first row and mental
health practitioners that's likely a
result of the board rules being
promulgated in state fiscal year 2020
and the boards having more of a direct
hand and compliance followup and please
feel free to stop me and interrupt me if
you have any
questions okay representative Weber yes
I just had one preliminary
yes what's the reason for the 2-year lag
in the
data it takes a long time to clean and
organize and Report visualize the data
um It's really because our staff
capacity um within the program is me as
uh sort of the epie as well as the
administrator um and then we just hired
in this last year um a data analyst
programmer to try to speed things along
but it's a steep learning curve we're
hoping um to have turnaround time about
a year after we're not there yet is that
because the data is reported in all
kinds of different formats from all kind
of different people not in different
formats we maintain the survey tool
within the program but the licensed
renewal Cycles differ I know that oplc
has changed that as of you know February
I think of 2023 they're starting to move
to Rolling renewals but with this data
before then it was that aprns and mental
health practitioners were just on
rolling Cycles While others like Pas
were October to December um adex were
April to June so it sort of is
scattered you're
welcome okay the average response rate
across provider types is 90% right which
is great we're hoping to maintain or
increase that rate for Reliable
representative data um with continued
compliance enforcement by
oplc now completion of the opt out form
does Meet The Lure requirement we love
to see that it's remained low though
since implementation it remains at about
1 to 2% um and it's great because the
rich survey collected from the survey
tool really does allow for those
in-depth specialty analyses for
comprehensive Workforce
assessment
okay so page
two page two contains uh Supply changes
according to the license list figures
maintained by oplc so the net change
percent that's all the way to the right
um demonstrates no true loss of
providers during State fiscal year 2021
um we see that psychologists broke about
even um minimal increases for physicians
in adax and then some saw significant
gains especially for APNs where we see
Workforce gains nearing 25% and PAs at
20%
now I'm sure you're all thinking this
but the increases likely do come in part
as a result of several executive orders
issued during the New Hampshire covid-19
state of emergency that ease barriers to
lure and clinical practice so
unsurprisingly right we see this influx
of aprns and P pasas that have very
similar scopes of practice as Physicians
right they can work in a variety of
settings and they can practice largely
independently
what's not clear with the licensing list
figures is um whether these new
providers are practicing at the top of
their license or whether they're just
aiding in in pandemic efforts um so
we'll just continue to analyze this data
see how future um years compare um I
have a guess but uh we'll see that shake
on all
righty page three here I'm just going to
highlight a few interesting Workforce
statistics for medical providers um
there's much more in the in the full
report but these um few sort of stuck
out to me so table 4.1 has the
percentage of clinically active
providers across medical provider types
that's those providers who have an
active status license that are
clinically practicing in New Hampshire
we can see about 3ars of AP aprns are
doing that over 90% of PA
but the physician rate is just over 60%
considerably less and that's a rate we
see consistent year to year um I love to
point this out at every opportunity
because it really um shows value for
this program if we were only to use the
lure list to estimate Supply we would be
grossly overestimating the supply of
physicians in this
state table 4.2 shows the percentage of
primary care providers of those
clinically active in New Hampshire um
Physicians and aprns are about 20% of
those clinically active are in primary
care practice 16% of Pas there is no
National Benchmark here um but this
percentage does fall short of the
recommended 40% of active providers in
Primary Care by the na uh National
education table 4. four uh summarizes
anticipated Supply indicators which um
obviously helps to paint the picture of
future healthc care supply in the state
so the first couple um provider age this
helps to inform anticipated Supply where
younger providers can offset uh
Workforce shortages that come from
provider retirement um we can see that
for primary care aprns about a third um
of them are uh under 40 years old this
is about two times higher than those 60
years and older for Pas we see an even
greater Gap that 45% are under 40 um and
that's three and a half times those that
are um 60 years or older however we see
the very opposite is true for Physicians
where um about a third or 60 years and
older and this is about 2 and a half
the anticipated practice figures for uh
primary care physicians also a bit
discouraging here we see about a third
of primary care physicians anticipate a
reduction in practice in the next 5
years of that of those about
20% plan to not practice in New
Hampshire at all so that's either by
practicing in another state or just
ceasing clinical practice
altogether I will say that these
statistics it's it's not on the chart
but um I like to you know add some of
the um comparisons that I can from the
previous year these statistics are a bit
worse than what we saw in 2020 data um
so that suggests right that this these
indicators were likely impacted by the
pandemic so we'll see if this changes um
oh actually I want to add just a one
more thought or a couple of thoughts to
this
um Bleak picture that I painted for a
physician Supply in this in the state we
do see right this big picture that we
can expect a continued decrease in
physician Supply um however a a key
practice measure that could offset this
is inate training inate residency um we
have three Family Medicine residencies
currently in the state we have two
underdevelopment in rural areas um
that's Coos family and and Cheshire
Family Medicine residencies we can
expect the primary care physician to
increase Supply to
increase um with increased access to
instate training um the other
consideration here is with uh respect to
supply gains um education Trends and
retention indicators that we saw here
it's possible that aprns could also
counterbalance this um future physician
loss uh while you're on that subject uh
could you tell me where the three Family
Practice residencies in New Hampshire
are
located yes one is at Dartmouth
Hitchcock Medical Center right yes I'm
goingon to one is at the conquered
hospit it is connected to Dartmouth
Hitchcock at conquered hospital and the
the other is the Portsmith Regional
Hospital thank you I believe
that yes those was are still yes just
yes Miss Jim thank you yes go ahead
doctor do you have that broken down um
as to where these anticipated uh
reduction and practice in 5 years are
located meaning that is it worse in the
North country the western side of the
state or southern part of the state or
where is it most where is it where we
going to feel that feel that impact most
we do we are going to move actually to
to um that breakdown not by Public
Health Region not by you know Town level
not by county level um we do see well we
do break it down by rurality so rural
versus non-rural in previous years we
did see that there was a discrepancy
there that there were higher rates of
anticipated reduction in practice in
rural areas we don't see that with this
data we're guessing because of the
pandemic and provider burnout so it's
because of a spike in non- rural rates
is why we're no longer seeing that
discrepancy question for either one of
you um is the medical school at
Dartmouth holding steady with the number
increasing I I haven't heard of
additional seats um being added to the
program but I don't know that it's
increased at all but it is relatively
new as is a chesher one okay um no I
mean at the med school you want to go be
an MD and oh w w how many are graduating
and going into Primary Care no is the
number graduating constant or are they
increasing the spots there I believe
that number is St fairly stable okay but
the number of people going into primary
care has dropped off
precipitously University of New England
in bitterford Maine is increasing its
number of spots and we know osteopaths
tend to prefer uh Primary Care uh at a
much larger rate than MDS so there is
some help there and especially with
ports Smith's uh residency right and I
believe there's also opportunity through
un to have some clinical rotations in
rural parts of um the state through
their program
well we're not rural in Kingston
although we don't have very many people
there but we do take such rotations at
the facility I'm part-time CEO of so
there's hope yes thank you
welcome okay so um looking at table uh
four this is the breakdown of practice
by geography and clinical practice so we
see across all provider types about a
third of practice
is in rural um with primary care
practice representing only a fraction of
total practice um especially for Pas
where we see um primary care practice
extremely limited um just that 3% um it
makes it so that we can't really get
those filters on there to dive into the
data um for
Pas uh as we can for aprns and
Physicians the figures one and two right
under that table come a new analysis to
this report showing primary care uh
practice distribution by Public Health
Region and as a proportion of total
practice um overall practice it should
be represented by a blue bar I believe
it's black because our copy are only
prints in black and
white and outpatient primary care
practice as a proportion of total
practice should be an orange I believe
it's in Gray um and we see with this
that while overall practice is more
variable across the state right we see
um high amounts of practice in Upper
Valley in figure one for the rural
Public Health regions and also very high
in Greater
Manchester in figure two um with the
non-rural public health regions but what
we see for primary care practice is it's
more consistent across the state
Hampshire all right so page five uh
tables 5.1 through 5.3 show significant
differences in provider and practice
characteristics by rurality so all of
these characteristics here aren't those
that were tested it's those that were
found to be statistically um different
between rural and non- rural um areas of
the state some interesting changes not
on there but that I want to point out
again from 2020 analysis um to point out
just because it's likely pandemic
related is that there's no longer as I
said a difference in anticipated
reduction of practice between rural and
non-rural um areas because of the spike
and non-rural rates um the other
difference um is that or other change is
that there's no longer a difference in
the rates of imgs or International
Medical graduates between rural and
non-rural because of a spike again in
non-rural
rates a new trend we see um across all
three provider uh all three provider
types is that is a higher rate of newly
trained providers in rural compared to
non- rural um according to the
indicators graduation within the last 10
years for all three types and then
practice in New Hampshire for un uh
under five years for APNs and PAs um
we'll see again right if this trend
continues or if it's an artifact of the
pandemic um I would be remiss if I
didn't point out two characteristics and
and that sort of go along with that idea
I said earlier about really the
importance of um you know training and
and pipeline for our providers um it's
that rural Physicians are more likely to
have graduated from a New Hampshire
Medical School and and to have trained
in a residency within the state these
findings we see consistent year-to year
um and it is important right because it
tells us that if we want greater access
to healthcare and work we need to
efforts representative Merchant thank
chair thank you for taking the question
you're welcome if one of the key factors
is graduating from a school medical
school in New Hampshire is there any
thoughts of working with University of
New Hampshire to create a medical school
I mean not trying to take away from
medic Dartmouth but if we have a growing
need and one of the factors is where
they graduate
from is there any discussion going on
about trying to find a way to develop a
medical school or osteopathic school
either one um in New Hampshire itself
with unb instead of the
basis I haven't heard those discussions
um I I will say you know obviously apart
from Physicians and speaking about
another advanced practice type APRN UNH
does have a grant um called a new
advanced nursing education Workforce um
program where they are training APRN
specifically to work in rural areas and
unders medically underserved areas of
the state so I do know that that
initiative um is ongoing with with
Federal grant with a Federal Grant I
haven't heard those discussions but
certainly it's worth bringing up at um
one of the upcoming uh commission
meetings on the interdisciplinary
Primary Care
Workforce thank
you Senator Rosenwald and I are over
here plotting in some things so yeah yes
well that's why this right report is so
important to bring this to policy makers
attention um you all are the ones that
really affect the change so um and we're
always happy to have you at that Primary
Care Commission meeting any further
other representative uh whoever has the
don't we we were we were told we were
told from the floor the other day that
if women just had more babies
anyway uh any other questions because we
have exactly two minutes left all right
we're we've made it to the last page I'm
hoping to get through this one because
this is another um exciting new analysis
that we added uh to this report and and
plan to continue to keep it in this
report moving forward um this is the
primary care provider rate per
population um we can see here in table
6.1 that rates are highest for
Physicians um at 54 Primary Care um FTE
providers per 100,000 resident
population um but if we look at the
supply by licenses in the state at the
bottom of the page here we can see
there's many more Physicians licensed in
the state at 8,500 than there are aprns
you know there's twice the number of as
there are aprns and especially um Pas so
with this in mind um the rate of you
know 30 providers per resident
population for AP parents is relatively
High when taking Supply into
consideration the combined out patient
Primary Care rate is about 94 that's the
last row in the first um table that
translates to um one primary care
provider for every 1,66 people now um
sort of as I had said with the
percentage of um primary care providers
relative to all um active providers in
the state there is no hard and fast
Benchmark for this but wh estimates that
at least two and a half Primary Care
Providers per 1,000 people are needed
for adequate Primary Care coverage and
that's one and a half times as many as
we have statewide according to this
analysis what was the number
yes looking at table 6.2 um this ranks
the uh Public Health regions by rate so
we can see actually the top three rates
are all in rural um upper valleys number
one this should really come as no
surprise Dartmouth Hitchcock Medical
Center sits in Upper Valley it also has
a very low resident population which you
can see in the right hand column here
however the next two North Country and
Caroll County we see as demonstrated
successes of the benefit of shortage
designation and the grant opportunities
and the funding that follow to
strengthen Workforce initiatives in
areas and that's all I have I may made
it in 20 minutes are there any
additional
questions good thank you for your report
you're very
welcome I have the um tentative agenda
for the next month's meeting which is
slated for Friday May 24th now the
Monday is Memorial Day I don't know if
that will pose a problem to anyone I'm
around but
uh do we want to try to move that
or I'm okay with it okay with it okay
I'm going to hand out
mys
toest or answer any survey tool related
questions okay one for you one for me
thank
you so um it looks like our next meeting
will be Friday May 24th 2024 thanks
adjourned with the St Health System it
is in bankruptcy it's a for profit
hospital we don't have enough money to
with C just
million um I would
not
nonprofit's I believe it is private for
profit and if you want to have a board
of directors and be run well then I can
support some State funds to hospitals
many Hospital oh I've done that not a
problem we only go 36
hospitals I think we have fewer than
that see do you know how many hospitals
something